officers and those members of the public
that are here at the meeting this
evening and for those joining us
virtually
welcome to tonight's toronto council
full pencil meeting
we're where we have a really full agenda
with many topical reports
which i'm sure will spark some lively
discussion and delay
in fact to begin as chair of the tourist
system council
i thought it would be fitting but before
we discuss matters close to home we
spare some time
and think of those further afield and in
particular
ukraine
we have all seen the images and reports
of the atrocities kept in the lives of
ukrainians
either sheltering under siege or fleeing
war
areas um
you know to find safety food and shelter
which we all take for granted it really
puts things into perspective
as with all councils across the country
taurus recurrence is supporting the
effort to help those coming to our
district and our officer team
are working closely with the other
district councils and dedicated council
to facilitate this which i'm sure my
fellow councillors will be all happy to
help our police support
so before our meeting starts i think we
should take a moment to reflect and to
show our support to ukraine
for those directly involved in the
conflict those fleeing and the families
and friends of those who have sadly lost
their lives and as a result of this
terrible invasion
so
if we could all please stand for one man
thank you very much
okay moving into the agenda the first
item is apologies for evidence
yes thank you chair councillor
pennington councillor
councillor bright councillor hawkins
chancellor watson
councillor hackett councillor hutchins
and councilman claudia pankin
thank you
item two is to confirm the minutes of
the full potential meetings on the 31st
of january on the special budget meeting
on the 21st of february
i went through the
first one on the 31st of january page 5
eleven
and twelve
thirteen
one fourteen
reach
fifteen sixteen
[Music]
that's brings us to a conclusion can i
either
transfer mutant proposals
second bond transfer memory all in favor
please sure
and
again extensions
thank you
and then we come on to the 21st of
february
budget meeting
first place 17
[Music]
this one
okay and again
abstentions
three on the agenda we've got uh public
contributions we've got five speakers
forecasting council's constitutional
loan is three minutes per speaker
so that's the allocation we have a very
full agenda this evening i'm sure you've
tweaked that from the
number of items we've got on the agenda
so i'm gonna be fairly strict with that
so the three minutes will start
when you start speaking
the first one is stacy there
no no stacy taylor stacy taylor here
juicy hole
that would come with the front the
microphone
this one yeah just uh
[Music]
okay
okay so you'll have to forgive us
there's three of us to speak and i was
going to go last so this may or may not
make perfect sense but it will by the
end okay
i'm here uh as a member of biddeford
empty homes working group to support
councillor craven's notice of motion on
the empty homes policy
i've joined the town council empty homes
working group as i've been really
concerned about the housing crisis and
seeing firsthand the effects of what
this is doing in our community
so i started to look at what other areas
outside of our area are doing about this
and about the issue of empty homes and i
just wanted to share a couple of
examples with you tonight so plymouth
reduced its number of long-term empty
properties by 235 last year
this has largely been attributed to a
dedicated team of empty homes officers
working proactively with owners and
using enforcement measures such as
management orders and for sales of the
last resort
exeter have been working from their very
comprehensive
2019-22 empty home strategy using a
really creative raft of measures
delivered by a dedicated empty homes
team
this team worked really closely with
others such as the environmental health
and lendology cic who i believe torrid
already worked with
and again they work to support owners to
financial support using enforcement only
when all else has failed
whilst bringing long-term empty
properties back into use won't solve the
housing crisis it can have a really
positive impact on not just the amount
of available properties but also the
well-being of our community
living with long-term empty properties
can have a detrimental effect on
neighbours and neighborhoods lowering
property values and increasing
environmental health issues
a member of the working group be here
this evening has asked me to recount her
friend's experience of living next to a
problem long-term empty property in
biddeford so i'm just going to read her
words to you
al had to deal with the stress and worry
of living in a house which was in a
worsening state due to the attachment
over the years she spent a lot of time
in correspondence with the owner of
number one but no progress was made and
in the end elle just gave up trying to
secure her legacy to her voice who
obviously meant the welter
the frustration and feeling of
unfairness and her being ignored i know
made her first very angry and then very
tired
elle was a person who was excellent at
making things happen and developing good
relations but she had no power to turn
to that could help her out with her in
transient labor
i don't know what the reasons are for
the lack of action by the local
authorities on behalf of l and let's not
forget the wider community but this kind
of situation seems to me to be
unnecessarily stressful and very likely
injurious to the mental and physical
health of those affected
elle died with the situation unresolved
and i know that she hoped her two boys
who are now young adults would sell up
and buy places of their own the
impossibility of this happening under
the current circumstances i know that's
right
okay thanks listen
nicholas radford
here you
you have your three months starting
asia
nicholas thank you
currently torridge has 76 properties
currently paying the long term
anti-properties council tax premium
the most recently just
either closer to the
microphone the most recent figures from
long-term properties from the ministry
of housing communities and local
government report 250 such properties in
college
that's rising
combined with a number of properties
registered as second homes
this means
as of november 2021 one in every 27
properties and torridge is entered
each of these empty homes over time
becomes a worsening issues for the
community in the built environment
issues of health and safety misadventure
spotting crime arson the list goes on
the council has an ethical and legal
duty to implement policies
that assist in resolving these issues of
empty hands
there are powers and tools the council
must use to engage with these serious
issues
but presently these are either out to
date and not implemented
we urge the council to review the empty
homes policy
and look to employ a dwelling management
order
look to
mt dwelling management orders to obtain
building stock we urge the council to
act to assist property owners to making
good empty homes and putting them back
into rental markets
we urge the council
to create an empty home's opposite
position to manage and track empty homes
and most importantly we urge the council
to listen to its constituents
as homelessness is rising significantly
which is just perverse when there are so
many empty homes sitting there
thank you
thank you for having me guys
thanks for
[Music]
jameson the course i've seen you here so
you have to come forward
evening i'm counsellor caicos
for town council
i have just three minutes to use my
voice and my experience to gain your
support on risk motion this evening
homelessness is complex it tears
communities apart and destroys the lives
of many
the issue of homelessness cannot be
fixed with one action
it needs a multi-faceted approach
it needs us
to be creative
bold
brave and to try things that have not
been tried before
in august 2021 our motion beautiful 10
councils declare a housing emergency and
after this we started the empty homes
working group
my job within encompass is a senior
supported accommodation worker
just in biddeford we accommodate 15
people
all of those people were homeless before
moving into the accommodation
we try and get them back on track and
when they're ready to move into
independent accommodation again we
helped them find that accommodation it's
always been difficult to do that and now
it's not only possible
people that remain homeless will be more
at risk of becoming what we call
entrenched homeless entrenched
homelessness is when someone has been
homeless for at least six months or more
homelessness doesn't just leave you
without a home it destroys your life
it scars you
and takes your hopes and dreams away
strips you over dignity and self-worth
it weakens our society and creates
further weight on statutory and charity
services
not only does it have a financial cost
to us
or it has a life cost
just a few hours ago i looked deaf in
the face
and life turned off too soon
i feel like i could shut up into a boat
and pieces right now in front of you but
that's not going to help you then or i
if you support who likes motion you
support us on working with something
that could help provide homes for the
people i've spoken about
we need to look forward we need to work
together
and refuse to let the hazy crisis
continue to cause the damage that it's
causing
will you
help us to do something that could
produce homes for those in this
community
will you
help us to stop the revolving door of
homelessness that is killing our
communities and our people
bringing empty homes back into use isn't
going to end homelessness on its own but
it's one piece
of the puzzle that you
have the power to bring into action
thank you
[Music]
item four on the agenda
uh declarations of interest so
you will not score on that there are any
other items on the agenda but you need
to declare you do so when will be
discussed
item five is the agreement of agenda
items part one and two so there are part
two items so i need to have a proposal
and secondary
council hudson thanks to clark all in
favor pleasure
[Music]
[Music]
i don't have anything in particular so
we're going to
item seven to answer questions submitted
on the procedural rule a9
four questions have been submitted
one from councillor bright two from
council of all things and one
professional
the answers have been tabled as required
under the constitution
so we'll get them in the order they've
been received excellent is given as
apologies
after the weekend is
[Music]
we'll have two a9 questions from council
hawkins one has been tabled and the
other one has been rejected as it does
not meet the requirements of george's
constitution to be heard potentially
republicans has given some qualities and
therefore i'll ask our head of legal and
monitoring officer to convey the reasons
for rejecting this question directly to
him tomorrow
chelsea ford's question has also been
rejected
i donate petitions
[Music]
that aren't on petitions received
so item nine um is a presentation from
benefit railway heritage center
and i'd like to invite
tim steer to come up and give his
10 minute
10 minute presentation
thank you
[Music]
good evening torridge i'd just like to
say tonight that i have news from
oakhampton
that uh last year the uh west end
councillor kevin paul said that his
railway when it's restored will make his
town prosper
and only on saturday the report came out
to say that his town now has got
certainly the most usage it has in years
they are now getting to the point that
they're asking shops to open early
stay open later over seven days a week
and agents are looking for more open
units to make more shops
and
businesses prosper
my name is tim steer i am the parish
councillor for framington parish
councillor for tallstock
i am part of the committee for the top
rail association
and i'm director of biddeford railway
heritage centre
so tonight
i will show you my presentation
and i've made this project the atlantic
coast express
that is
acerel for short
and he's got some good honest
truthfulness about this we are the
atlantic coast and we couldn't really
see potential of being restored back to
the national network
excitement
so the last train
in 1982 benefits saw its
last special networks national network
service
the scheduled passenger service
finished in 1965
and that was proposed beaches and
beechen obviously
cut off home of north devon and a lot of
torrid we have now got to the point
where
we have problems with our passengers
services of getting into buying school
we all know that especially the numbers
that come through
so
2022 is the 14th anniversary from the
lion's closure
that picture here shows the 1982
special service and some of the 843
passengers who used that
day next slide please
restore your railway
this is the central government's um
scheme so it works with councils the
support left behind communities benefit
is exactly that
it regenerates local economies it gives
access to jobs
education
supporting new housing developments
and boosting tourism and of course it
cuts down on car emissions and eases
road congestion that includes remember
haulage companies can get to
destinations quicker as well as career
companies if there's less track on the
roads next slide please
okay there's 31 000 residents in greater
biddeford that's
biddeford
northern appledore and western home
combined and sustrans have this lovely
summary that we should all kind of take
on
integrating walking
and cycling with public transport is
essential
for making it easier for people to leave
their cars at home and councillors that
picture is not some utopian vision
that is eczema that's the x-muff to
exeter line
and which sees nearly a million users
per year and that's x-trail that runs
next to it so they have got exactly that
sustainable public transport and
integrated active traffic
next slide please
devon county council's benefit of rail
and balance ball railway safeguarding
in 1999
uh devon county council torridge
district council north denver district
council
paid a team
to carry out a feasibility study called
the montsell report
the report stated that advancement
bypass
was to be built with enough height
for a future railway
and also the route would need to be
investigated in the future
today you will see double decker bustle
buses using that
sat
underpass if you go to barnstable
railway station you will see this as you
leave the station you look towards
silverpath hill is the bypass
and under there there's enough height
clearance on the left hand side of it
you will see it's been safeguarded for
future railway and it's never been used
next slide please
the monsoon summary so this is from the
1999 summary of uh feasibility
and muscle therefore recommended that
bypass is to be constructed
with without the underpass but with
sufficient clearance that it can be
added at later dates
and secondly no further encroachments
on the route are committed
next slide please
basketball bypass so i have been talking
to devon county council's bridge and
retaining wall and sectors
and they've
shown me how exactly this would work
from the last feasibility study
here we have barnstable railway station
the
new restored railway to biddeford would
cut across the car park to the bypass
the a361 when it will happily go
underneath the bypass
then it will cut across here to the
a3125 which was made with a raised
profile this raised profile means that
the engineering works mean that the road
will not be disturbed when the railway
goes through with a new culvert
and then the railway then will continue
towards framington and onwards to
biddeford
next slide please
okay so the tarka rail
have certain
stations and some of them that you will
recognize
certainly some stations on the left-hand
side you will know quite well because
where everyone uses them
and there are some that
get a lot of usage and like exeter
and advance them with over 400 000
and then there are some that do not get
very good uh usage due to the fact that
they got a low amount of population
there in the little parish such as
chapelton or newton's state size
but there are some there that are
looking a bit confusing
such as
eggsford only 145 parishioners
just over 1 000 users
but over 32 000 views and 32 000
passengers
so there is a reason behind this i would
like to explain it next slide please
gwr that's the great western railway has
agreements to always stop at tarpon line
stations some of these are request stops
and some of these definite stocks
to serve the catchment areas
exeter we know
crediton is a very well used station in
fact they've got an accountant so they
are very happy with their uh
uh eggersford is the transport hub and
it's serving chumley weekly and surely
and advanceful there's too many to
account for here councillors they go all
the way from linton uh
you willocu it there are two certainly a
lot of places that
use barnstable
and then greater benefit if we think the
same
as advancing with the near enough the
same population we could see
that we would have a similar number or
more
okay next slide please
and here is the proof that i want to
explain that
what they call transport and justice
this is where beechen cut off one town
however the other town
really wasn't uh prepared to be cattle
and it carried on with an uh expanded
population hillard
32
948 in the population well uh sorry
advancement that is our benefits just
behind with thirty one thousand and
fourteen
now if barnes spawn has gone over
[Music]
in fact
this is
complete proof
why biddeford is the largest town in the
whole of devon
without a railway
in next slide please
torridge is ranked as the lowest four
percent gdp per capita the whole uk a
restored railway service would bring
economic prosperity to the entire area
benefit residents would gain much needs
employment opportunities without the
need to own a private vehicle
next slide
torridge district is ranked as the
lowest 2
weekly earnings
of great prison it needs leveling up
next slide please
so why benefit a great benefit resident
population over 30 000
and growing all the time the number
doubles to sixty thousand in some time
it gives sustainable access to visitors
the
a398361 b three two three three
congestion relief is in line with the
central government's carbon neutral
targets access for thurman and higher
education students and tremendous
opportunities
have you got much more to do i think i'm
about oh there's one more page
as we add two speakers less very quickly
okay thank you
um
the local plan so
benefit rejoining the national network
needs to be added to the new north devon
toronto plan
a restored mainline railway service
by advanced schools needs some
developments of recovering years as well
established communities
with sustainable public transport
we must present to north devon district
council why benefit needs ourselves they
have passed a motion counsellor they
would like to see this happen i need to
present to torridge district council and
i'm here today to show you this and for
benefit to rejoin the national network
the new joint local plan for torridge
and north devon needs a policy
commitment to find and protect a route
and once both district councillors have
uh resolved such policy
to be included
count council officers will write it in
as for a matter of future public and
stakeholder consultations and can gather
more widespread support can i just show
the last slide please
these are my proposed starting points i
can just tell you now that they have all
been tipped off and we've formed a
bit of the town council ace rail
committee uh include orange and north
devon district councils our stem county
council commission transport and support
devon county council transport me as
said she does not want lobbying she
supports this
and we include network rail and gwi
meters i have been
the strategic case officer is on this we
are the devon desert they call us and we
park funded independent specialist
advisor to prepare prospectus
for asrell
and
for our future made part funding back
here giving me five thousand pounds
towards the project
you've had your
that's very good thank you thank you
very much
timmy may you may want to just sit there
just okay as any members won't
i've got any questions so yes do you
have an opportunity to know
you've got a few minutes to ask any
questions
that's right
all right sorry
very interesting presentation thank you
just a couple of questions really so
we're talking about restoring another
another train line and
as i understand it there's talk of that
in
the line from hamstock to plymouth i
know there's a connect view which is
trying to connect euler to
captain it really seems in vogue at the
moment we're trying to get all these
railway lines up and running again
however
for biddeford
all right i'm not a bit of a cat so i'm
not the resident but i've just had a
look and you seems like you have a bus
to bounce for every hour or half hour
that's correct
which would take you to the train
station and buses
at least from my experience seem to be a
lot cheaper
than train tickets whenever i go to look
at dragon ticket it seems to cost an arm
and a leg whereas a bus ticket always
comes in at less cost and as you rightly
say we are one of the poorest districts
in
in the country so
my question really is
given that you've got such good travel
links anyway with the buses and that
that will be cheaper than
[Music]
train fares
how can you really justify this
that's a very fair question um for a
start the buses will take from half an
hour on a good day
to
two hours to three hours on a day with
congestion advancement i've been told
plenty of residents have explained to me
that the need to get advanced for on
time is very poor at the moment and they
cannot justify sometimes taking
um the bus
the railway if it was restored would be
within 10 minutes
from the benefit to barnes ball now
[Music]
basketball to unbelieve the same
distance
to the benefit of um barnstall so if i
took the train to
unbelievable rail card that's three
pound 15 return
that would be a similar deal for
residents here
thank you for that i've got councillor
brandon first of those
very good presentation i'm really
delighted to see that come to port
torres because some of them were on the
council on top of the marshall report
at the time torres policy was to oppose
a demonstrating breach
in barnstable because it would chop off
the railway and i do believe that they
slightly sock means it actually will
make it viable for it to be restored
again
going back to the prices to talk about
just now by the council
actually
it will be a fantastic tourist i mean
it's one of the
prettiest routes it's even better than
the camera trail actually so i do think
it would bring in enormous revenue in
terms of tourism and will allow people
to come
into north devon from wherever in the
country by training as indeed they did
on the old devin bell which you know it
may be nostalgic but people are going
back to a greener forward transform so
we should be supporting it every inch of
the way on this council to have that
restored thank you
thank you
thank you jeff
um chair
yes there's always an alternative to you
you see now i can remember traveling on
that train and the wonderful view
going down to instill i was looking at
the young child and it was as if i was
on a boat
lovely but we have a much loved our
betrayal too
will the two be able to live together
that's a very good question now this is
what we call complementary scheme so we
do not want to take away the entire
patrol in one bit however this might
also suggest as we know some of us as
councillors that target throwing stages
has to be uh resilient against flooding
this might be a suggestion now in front
of you that we use the new line as a new
flood defense wall for the existing
trail
or that we have a raised profile or
um a new active travel route that runs
beside it there's other options that we
have that we could build the railway on
top of the target trail and have a
tunnel system for
locals to use for cyclists or even vice
versa but they can be on top and they
can be under internal with the railway
well i've been told about 18 different
ways that you can have this done and
including new cuttings with new
directions however i do want to retain
the tarka trail
thank you
special
[Music]
of like abandoning to point out as well
i don't know if anybody's studied at
petron lately but obviously we're trying
to
increase the capacity of that college if
you actually need to go there to study
i don't use the box i'm afraid i drive
there's actually nowhere to park
absolutely nowhere i might just want to
walk from billy foote sometimes because
it's just so congested surely that would
relieve some congestion of people being
able to pop on the train that literally
takes you right outside the main college
in north devon
it makes sense to me
north dakota councillors actually said
exactly what you've said
that the amount of congestion going into
barn school to the college has got to a
point where they can't find parking
space
and
if we've got a better public transport
system for them the students would use
it
we've got two more speakers newton first
um
i use the taka line quite a bit
um getting on at umberley
to connect with mainline uh
some davis in order to go up to london
um
and i would say as a state if you go
in a weekday in the morning or come back
late in the afternoon the train is
ranked it is standing room only
students
going to college in exeter largely but
the usage of that line has has improved
remarkably now i have no doubt that a
business case
to
justify
the financial benefit
versus the net out huge cost of what you
are some of the things you are
suggesting will be a very difficult
challenge
however i would i would say that that
the
putting aside any tourism benefit but
actually get getting young people moving
um is
it's quite an impressive sighting that
uh and i i use it quite a lot it's very
it's now especially with new um somebody
else's rolling stock on there which is
better than the last 20 buses we had is
actually um uh a good service to you
council hicks and i think you're going
to be the last one way overall five
minutes
thank you mr chairman
that's a good question well
how about a new biddeford parkway and
that we have like
oakhampton oak hampton have a bus finger
service the dark line the dart line goes
around oakhampton and then around have a
stop and one pound deliver you to the
train
ten minutes before the trains
departure so my journey from buckland
brewer will become somewhere near billy
bird to get on a bus
to get on the train
to get off the train at barnstable walk
over the bridge to the civic center or
wherever i want to go
a lot easier to drive isn't it
it's important for a game changer we
want to make people realize that they
don't need to use their car if there's a
faster service
can i just ask them
the ultimate aim if this came to
fruition it's not i take it just to go
from benefit to gospel no if you've
hooked up to the main line you could get
transformed from city for going straight
to london oh completely um barnstable is
already looking at um restoring its
platform too and on platform two they
will have overnight trains that will um
go early from
uh basketball to waterloo
and to axminster so there are more
services coming about so we could be
part of that a bit of it
thank you very much thank you
[Music]
[Music]
the field until then literally half by
six or
started in the computers
um i'll just jump straight in and talk
about it yeah sure um
so rather than sort of take up extra
time so if you go to the next cycle
so the unesco bias reserve was
designated in 2002 we've got
three functions so one of which is
conservation biodiversity sustainable
development in the second one
and knowledge generation non-sharing
being though
and if you
um
again this slide does seem to sort of
still surprise quite a few people but
you can see that the extent of the vice
reserve is actually all the river
catchments all the land that drains down
to the north didn't cost
so we're looking in in terms of the
whole ecosystem when we look at this but
it's also the communities
that live within there and
the extension around londy was
originally sort of placed on the
bathymetry of the depth of the water
there's been a natural system down here
but fishermen locally said
please extend it to 12 miles beyond
london because that's our ecosystem that
we're fishing we want our fish to be
themed as sustainably caught in the
bicycle reserve so we've extended out to
about 12 um
is there is a biodiversity crisis
that's globally accepted that we need to
do something about it
and the governor said we need to look at
new ways of trying to help address that
biodiversity crisis
and so with within that we ran two of
the four heidi's in the government's
25-year environment plan
and that was to look at a natural
capital approach which is looking at how
you can use biodiversity um
for the better of human society so you
look at all the benefits you get from
the natural environments whether it's
carbon sequestration food production etc
and make sure that they are maximized
because you get far more public goods
back up from that than
otherwise so it's actually cheaper to
work with natural systems than it is to
work onto the artificial systems
so the importance there is to actually
protect those natural systems
but by making it part of a natural
capital approach you can also look at
the private investment in there it's not
purely public side of things
um but that is one particular sort of
way that you can look at the natural
environment which is purely about that
those economics which is good but it
doesn't cover everything so next time
please
so even though we've got a vice preserve
here it's been
since 2002 um
things aren't
brilliant we're sort of better than a
lot of places but you can see from this
slide but just explain it that
the reddit areas are the areas where or
the kind of species related to those
habitats which are in decline
and
the
yellow ones are where they're stable and
the other bits in between the ones where
it's kind of okay but there's some ones
there that give a false signal so wet
woodland such as fall air in wet
woodland
species there you go massive increase
because it's one small action actually
makes a huge increase
but all the sort of big common habitats
whether it's scrubling
grassland et cetera they're the ones who
see that there's quite a large decline
in species
so
some things that are not quite right so
if you go to the next slide
[Music]
um please we've got a couple of good
things within north evidence we're
shouting about we're just going through
the pioneer so
this should have been an animated slide
so that the picture behind the garden
indeed the herring
that is the freshwater pearl mussel
so the freshwater pearl mussel in the
torridge is a very special population
um it's the
it's the largest in the southwest and
that particular population genetically
is different from those western
the rest of the country
so they are very special freshwater
pearl mussels not just any professional
films using the mns kind of tones of
things anyway
um likewise the coveting herring we
discovered with our work on
the fishery side of the marine party
the cleveland herring is um is different
from every other herring you find in the
muslim channel
the received wisdom is that the herring
sort of spawned the island and come down
just to channel and spread around the
galaxy et cetera
but what we've discovered is that the
cleveland herring actually arrives a
month earlier before the rest
and so it's actually spawning in a
different place it's morphologically
different and genetically different
from the rest of the heavy so we've got
a very special
race of herring that
we need to look at where they're
sporting some of the natural protectors
um much better so we've got a kind of um
a familiarity with our biodiversity that
um
in into north devon which is
is quite special but if calorie revenue
really was that special it really is
so next slide please
um
with the
nature recovery plan we looked at
a set of different species we've got a
lot of different experts together we've
sort of had a look down at
of research in northwest
but we looked at what is the the root
cause analysis of why some of these
things are declining and you get to the
bottom end of the chain then says well
it's climate change ultimately or lack
of training and regulation because we've
got some pesticides being wrongly
applied for example it could be over
intensification of farming
uh it could be
port or lack of woodland management for
example or lack of red deer and graceful
that's the decline of woodland
specialists
for the next slide
again looking at some of those where
there's big declines in the wrestling
species
again it's all about sort of different
sort of practices that go on there but
it comes down to consumer divine farm
policy etc
and
likewise with some of these you can see
so we've got the next slide please
so we created the uh nature recovery
plan which covers five different
habitats um
some of your offices were involved in uh
writing that plan as well as ourselves
the vice very team and all the partners
in the biosphere zone
um next slide
and it's it's introductory chapter there
looks at you know what the vision is so
we want you know 30
of the semi-natural habitats in good
condition and over the rest of the
seventy percent of the everyone is kind
of a general improvement in condition
and the way that these places are looked
after
and this is by 2030 which meets with the
international biodiversity targets
so you can see we've got sort of various
things included in there with
relating to the way we manage towns and
villages for example and also looking at
the various pieces that could be there
plus introducing some species that were
here in the past high mountain leaving
just a
we're going to the next slide
so you've got different delivery
mechanisms for this and um
[Music]
look at this particular torch point of
view
and obviously we've got the planning
policy how that is applied we've got
biodiversity net gain which is now uh
inscribed in the environment act that's
just been sorted in this year and north
dakota have used it um looking at
building with nature
in their planning proposals over in
north devon so we're trying to look at
ways that you can improve the
biodiversity within the developments
themselves
applying that gain means you have to go
through that mitigation hierarchy avoid
mitigate compensate
which means that any development comes
along this
normal biodiversity is on their site
look at ways to avoid harming that
biodiversity if they can't kind of avoid
that they have to try other ways to
enhance it in different ways on the site
and then the last step is about
compensation offsite and it's not just
compensation now it's a ten percent gain
so that's where that particular policy
comes in but i'll be doing a session for
the planning committee in a few weeks
time
[Music]
so we can look at the kind of
improvement in the public realm uh to
help uh improve biodiversity so it
doesn't have to be all sort of
sterilized um
planting that just has no biodiversity
vitamins at all some of them sort of
actualize to semi-naturalized species
that you could put into flower beds or
whatever or to manage the parklands that
we have would be sort of a great step
forward
and likewise sort of supporting in terms
of community campaigns because we have a
program called pledge financial which is
locally funded so we've gone on for
another year and through that we sort of
try to get individuals to sort of do
their best for biodiversity and another
tourism north dakota districts will
constantly do their part within that to
help sort of galvanize action from the
individuals around the area
and then in supporting the different
biosphere projects that we have across
the partnership because there's 33
partners in the basketball reserve
including the district councils
obviously we've got some large ones like
devin woods which is about creating
woodlands to reduce phosphate runoff
from land and actually improve water
quality we use flooding
and natural solutions is a very similar
one with double wildlife
trustworthiness restoration to improve
those ecosystem services and benefits
and of course
this is our work again supporting
farmers to getting more into the hybrid
environment schemes and the nails for
the elms
schemes that comes online in a couple
years time
and
as we're trying to do is set up a
virtual capital investment model
about 50 million which is there to
invest in those projects and then give a
return so it's that linking that
biodiversity gain on private investment
and what it does for you in society
so there's quite a lot of different ways
that the district council can get
involved in any of these and it just
means that the next slide
i'll skip that one
[Music]
that's where it was today this is
looking at how we change land use but
improve the monitoring of it so we can
look at all the benefits
and try and monetize that on the next
slide
this actually talks to the last
presentation about the railway where
we're looking at uh trying to reduce the
pressures on the more sensitive buyers
decides from tourism
and
transport is going to be one of the key
things you can do but let's go to the
next slide
so in summary chairman so we are still
losing biodiversity at home
sorry a large rate
and
it does take partnership between all
those different organizations working to
resolve it it's not just something that
tourists can do when it's on it's not
like the advisory does on its own it
does it in partnership with the national
government and
ngos as well
tdc has a more important role to play
now thanks to the environment
james you are thank you
brings a lot more duties onto the
district council which you know we'll
talk about a later time but that's where
we need to do some more work
um planning and the proper use of
biodiversity net gain is going to be one
of
the
um but again it's about leadership the
voice of the authorities and how people
support local communities and their
groups wanting to do things through the
way that you survive that public ground
in particular
and i just agree besides working in
partnership was critical and we look
forward to enjoying that advice
well i'll be very surprised if you
haven't got some hands shoot up probably
coach and haynes is going to be the
first one yes he is
[Music]
um could you just give us maybe a bit
more detail about what our role would be
under the environment act um as you
can see
yeah the environment has got sort of
several sort of touch
the district council all planning
authorities local forests have the duty
to have regard to
um biodiversity now within the
environment act it says they have to
definitely promote an in-house
so it means that uh
by law now the district council was
attention do need to certainly take a
much stronger role in my universe
um it is enabled with the introduction
of the net gain within the um
the planning act which means you know
the ultimately 10 gain i mean loss of
biodiversity from development
which is one of the things it's one of
the it's not the biggest cause of these
one of these sort of larger causes
of biodiversity loss
so it is really through those days but
it's also meaning that
you need to track
and look at the condition of
biodiversity within the district as well
so that's where we can do that in
partnership with the vice reserve
district the north dakota district
council as well as the county council
that's the advantage of working
partnerships
[Music]
yeah mine is more of an admin question
really um i sit on the plans committee
and we're always talking about off-site
um net gain and sometimes that off-site
is miles away from where the plan
aggregation is
do you as an organization decide where
the money goes or can a small landowner
and i'm talking about in particular in
part my world has got two fields in a
big in a biodiversity can they apply to
you or do you direct when the money goes
no no um
what we're trying to do is actually set
up a natural capital marketplace which
includes um where
some landlords want to sort of provide
land for biodiversity so the idea is
they've come into their suggested what
they want to do
we calculated the biodiversity credits
there's a special calculation that
looking to produce so he said how much
bike versus going to sort of race on
that land yeah we've been reaching out
to
around the area um
[Music]
we didn't have anybody round right but
with all the sacks we had
[Music]
yeah
so
if there is a farmer nearby we can help
them
prepare their case to to make it put my
diversity in that game and as a rule
we'd like to get as close to the
developments as possible
um what the calculator allows it says
anywhere in the same planning authority
area
so in terms of the the
like calculation of the metrics and the
value
as far as the goal
is within courage
development that's fine but um from a
biodiversity and connectivity point of
view i would say the closer we need to
develop that better
[Music]
a true price
um but also you know it could kind of
balance out because you have developers
so the same one there's affordability
issues but the law requires them to do
it now
um but obviously with different
marketing it makes it at least as
easy as it can
what would
[Music]
if
[Music]
at the very short term yes it is off to
some potential the dog isn't very sort
of long term hundred years or so the
coverage is going to be on the top
regularly i see so things are going to
change
and one of the slides that we had on
there which is kind of skipped was about
looking at natural fluid management the
evolution of the estuary from the course
of how it's going to happen over the
next hundred years and how we can apply
that
um because we're going to do salt marsh
from the estuary we're going to use um
some of the freshwater marshes around
the edge because then i could get more
and more sailors and we need to make one
more steps back
to that biodiversity it's a fact of why
the coasts change
um there's things we can do in the short
term because obviously what we don't
want is that landfill sites
[Music]
um so we need to look at that of course
we'll manage much more carefully um
and look at that but we've got to accept
that the way the sea levels are rising
is not going to be the defense of the
site in 100 years time
but there's obviously
things to do with adapting and that
means
[ __ ] shocking
i've got one question you don't have to
labor too much but um
probably
getting over about 20 years ago there
was a presentation about uh college in
the theater you may well have been there
i remember the public ask
devon county council's chief engineer i
think it was called ed chalton
um
if normal girls if the contents of
norman morrow's tip the former refugee
is such a problem why don't we just
remove the tip and the answer from him
20 years ago
was quite shocking actually
the latest available cost 20 years ago
to remove the contents of northern tip
if you could get
permission from the secretary of state
to find another landfill site to
tip it in which you wouldn't get because
they were banned
[Music]
was a hundred million pounds
and that was 20 years ago
so
given that was 20 years ago and it was
gonna cost a hundred million pounds you
know you could probably double that but
the question i'm really asking is
we can be
losing northern boroughs in its entirety
let them deceive
inaudible the tip has to be defending
yeah i agree um when we started doing
that work back in 2008 on the digital
costal model
um it was to say well what's what is the
best option in the long term is it to
defend the site cut into an item is it
to defend it in the medium term
and look two ways when the technology
that you're going to extract from the
site but also to
recruit some of the value of the stuff
that's inside the site
and then think about that but it um but
obviously
there's always kind of advantages
obviously what we need is not an option
it is a it is a problem it has to be
dealt with
if you leave the
mining out of the site for too long sea
level's going to rise in which case you
can't even access it in the first place
so if it happens that has to happen
sooner but um
because there are other things to look
at you know because the gold club has
its cultural level
which needs to be sort of considered in
the round
but uh you're not going to be able to
defend the site in 100 years time
because that would be
really really expensive
if you just told the rate of sea level
rise there is a long footage to to
maintain
the scenic vents across
not just the old beverage but also down
the back as well so it sounds like
you're saying that at some point the tip
will have to remove that i would say so
all you you have to sort of literally
surround it that's the other option
well thank you andy for that
presentation was very interesting thank
you very much
the item 11 on the agenda is the member
of budget options working group and
understanding council james
ages 25 to 27 right thank you
as members know that the full council
meeting in february
it was decided that we would have a
working group looking at the budget and
ways of
saving money or using our money more
efficiently
and so i would set the task to formulate
formula committee well i have a few
problems with that because we can't use
members that are on ons scrutinies
because obviously they can't scrutinize
the decision they've already made
so i've gone through the list and i've
taken the
non-political view and included members
i feel can make a contribution
you have the members there which is the
league member the league member for the
financing audit
council
coaster by
council christie and comes to a lot i've
spoke to the leader of other groups and
that's been agreed
um
and i've just added since then just in
case anybody does drop off
rather than come back to
full council to ask for a replacement
the leader has the option of replacing
that person i would do it in
consultation with the other group
leaders um so i'm basically just asking
for you to agree through the formation
of that working group
um
so we get on with the job basically
have any questions thank you
counselor youtube's proposing that the
secondary second it all in favor please
share
[Music]
thank
thank
you
okay item 12 uh jim equipment
mobilization cost this is for active
torridge pages 28 to 30 and david hayes
is coming in on us
councillors
and this report quite sharp report
it seeks to add the installation of gym
equipment at the torridge leisure centre
and actually holdsworth ledger center to
the council's capital programme to
california balance on the legend
mobilization budget so if members recall
back in
august 2020 born
and we determined that the legislative
provided by a locally authority owned
trading company active torridge and an
implementation budget of 250 thousand
subsequent to that decision
um office of the council involved in
discussions would be as a time writing
report the current provider of bloody
services which is now reformed by roger
1610 and one of the discussion points
was the purchase of all of the wires of
the existing gym equipment at the
leicester centers
following those discussions
an agreement was reached to purchase the
gym equipment at holdworthy lecture
center for a value just over 15 thousand
pounds
and however they were going to keep the
sixteen ten will keep the gym equipment
at the northern side so we went through
a procurement size and purchased
the northern side cost of
three thousand that seems to be loophole
actually ninety four thousand pounds
because these assets are over ten
thousand pounds and cut them will last
more than a year their cost is capital
we need member approval to add to our
capitals programs that's retrospective
and the
mobilization budget that we have 250 000
pounds
including these capital purchases of gym
equipment will have approximately 64 000
pounds left at the end of the financial
year 2021-22
we're imposing
secret approval to carry those monies
forward
to deal with the distant things such as
things that we know we need to do like
new hairdryers at the center cctv some
external cleaning purchase of all your
equipment and remedial maintenance and
the position will obviously will come
clear now that we're actually in charge
of the leisure center
to see what works perhaps needs to be
done obviously previously identified
uh before we go to recommendations i'm
going to hand over to
council james who's the leader and chair
of active toys
[Music]
we are getting fairly good reports back
with the work we've done so far
i won't go into the finance because any
people stitch me up on that so basically
i'm just asking for approval for the
recommender and i will move the
recommendation for some of the money
being
moved and also
the unbalanced spent and mobilization
project at the end of finance from the
united states side into a serve to
utilize us outlined in the report post
2022
so at the moment
at the moment uh it's looking quite good
[Music]
so 16 10 want to sell us the northern
equipment
are they transferring it somewhere else
yeah yeah it's uh 1610 value they've got
other centers and they want to move
those pieces of equipment to other
centers so we will start we will start
and refresh
that sorry
okay that's good for balls and second in
can we show that
[Music]
okay how's everything animal so you just
stepped out of the room i hadn't
realized that perfect thank you
we'll record it as council mclaughlin
councilman he was out of the room for
that vote okay
yeah
next time okay
is the golden public space protection
order ages 31 75 and down
police act that any public square
protection of when placed in a location
must be reviewed therefore in three ways
a psp is basically like a bylaw
which sets out the provisions and in
place in the locality which is
comfortably
mainly through a fixed point of notice
or call to action against the
perpetrator
the this psp will be rates
control requirements that is uh dog
fouling dogs on lead dogs on the lead by
direction and that's works and defense
not to put the dominant lead when
requested to do so by an authorized
officer dog exclusion including the
summer western home beach van
which is a requirement of the rooftop
status
there have been some my updates and
modifications to the previous psbo
around how we deal with children's play
areas and the expanding of nuisance and
as defined in the ps4 to prove the
livestock and wildlife
and bothering and the expansion of espio
provisions to cover specified areas
[Music]
all of these modifications have been
detailed in the report
as required by the legislation we
consulted with statutory consultation
carried out a public consultation on the
draft provisions
over 214 responses to the consultation
is attached to the committee report as
was expected there's a range of strong
agreements put forward on these issues
however it would appear that overall the
provisions were supported by the public
and the council teams
[Music]
the issues are likely or having
to have a detrimental effect on the
quality of life
the issues are consistent in nature that
they are reasonable and that it just
applies to the switches because
therefore we put forward the dracula
as control was consulted on before
by this committee and i'm happy to take
any questions
thank you um if this is there and i've
missed it i apologize but um i i think
the wording is so close to players
you've got an issue where something like
the junior playground with victoria
palmer
is not enclosed it's open and my
understanding from the play strategy was
that some parks now do not have to be
fenced unless they open onto a road so
where do we stand in terms of dogs on
those areas and play areas that aren't
enclosed because there is no fencing and
they would not fall under these
provisions and for exclusion they would
still fall under them for dozenly by
direction and for the the fouling
provision
but to make
the um enforcement of the provisions
simple
we do
say that if the
area is enclosed
then there's no dog
that's a
more simple straightforward thing to
change
okay okay
any other questions
[Music]
yeah it's not thank you it's not
strictly central but there isn't
age 33
about separate progression for
problems
[Music]
um
just to highlight that there is
an increasing problem with dogs chasing
birds um particularly near the skern
area of the barrows and
this one about whether you or
maybe
just answer
whether
provision is being made to
um
[Music]
[Music]
and we have got plans to enhance the the
signage down there particularly around
breeding birds
um we did consider a separate pspo for
that area we had some discussions with
natural england they were happy with
these proposals as a
because we made it more explicit that
it's about um
interference to wildlife and
livestock so we would like to try with
these provisions and the enhanced
signage down there and increase
enforcement presence as well and see how
that goes it might be if that's not
successful we might have to come back
with a more specific ps4
for the for the buzz and and um the
boosting birds down there but
this is a sort of a practical solution
you think that we want to try first
before going down that road
yeah i've done this on here victoria
at
park
moment i think
you can have your dog off the knee
over and then
the outside rugby field
but not in the park
it doesn't make a lot of confusion there
now because you're not definitely lying
really where you can actually
leave a holiday
and i walk down to the rugby club
when they're at home
and um
i see lots of dogs in the park all over
the place
you know they people don't put them on
their leads
and it just
i've got to ask a question i mean we've
only got one dog
and
does the
powers go to the
park attendant as well don't do these
powers go
can he
issue fines for people who are
you know
do this thing
often he gives him a warning can he
actually give him
a fire
the dog warden function sits within how
our neighborhood enforcement team serves
the the officers who deal with the
variety they have to suffer behavior
knowledge that sort of thing so there's
actually
five authorised officers who can serve
fixed penalty notice for these for these
provisions and those five who've got um
additional powers granted from the
police policy satisfaction accreditation
which is community safety accreditation
scheme so we do actually have five
offices but they
work over a range of
functions
and we have some new path wardens i
believe that we just started
they're not authorized themselves to um
surface punching artisans and but um
they do
um challenge or they will be challenging
people who are letting their dogs um off
uh that leads and uh clarifying the the
two different locations within within
victoria park and the agreement that we
had with the previous pathways was that
if any of those
matters were ignored then we would get
our our neighborhood um enforcement team
involved and we would do joint um
patrols with the um with the park
wardens and it's just because they'll
staff a moving force we haven't yet done
that but that would be our intention
going forward i just come back yeah very
briefly well just to ask how many five
have we known
you know how many times do we find
people that that's in the report for dog
farmland i think that i think i've said
it was seven
um responsiveness
[Music]
um coastal laws maybe had your hand up
and custom accounts
thank you
thank you as quickly as you can with the
answers
so there are serious incidents but i do
have to say the beast racial regulations
in westwood
just wanted to ask mackenzie the
european the eu blue flag thing was in
effect
is there a new government edition
initiative coming out
i am not aware of that and but as far as
was concerned that the blue flag
scheme was still was still operating but
i'll take you a couple points about that
i would imagine that any replacement
scheme would
have similar provisions
um
penalty points because
we're all aware that torres can pass
whatever rules it likes it's it's
actually policing that's really
important and when i've read the report
it says um
we do issue warnings carry out
enforcement action as a result for
example over the period given above a
total of eight fixed penalty notices
have been served
the period above is six years is that
what you're saying eight penalties in
six years um
possibly um i
think it is from
2017
yeah
quite considerable
you for that report john no more we need
to take a vote on this don't we
but i'm quite prepared to propose this
from the chair because it is an
important mission and i'm sure it will
get more disappointed but please take
this message back gentlemen we do expect
more enforcement because the issue in
the park as councilwoman has mentioned
there are dogs learning about nearly all
the time and if you do mention it to an
owner you just get verbal abuse uh and
you know they don't mess in the town i
get the same comments from countries in
rosewood and oregon it is disgusting you
know and i'm not against dogs i love
dogs myself but there are a number of
irresponsible dog owners that need to be
brought to task and when they are it
needs to be publicized so that people
know tourists take this matter seriously
so clearly six or eight in six years is
unacceptable but
i'll move that we accept this
have a second
that's the money all available
thank you
there's any
okay thank you very much
um
item 14 is the uh
armed forces covenant pages 76 to 84.
uh and janet is going to do this in uh
with pressure
i'll come to you this evening to approve
our record
sorry
all right come to this evening for you
to approve
the recommitment to the armed forces
covenant
and the signing of the same
and to approve the development
with this commitment through a range of
actions proposed within the report
okay um united kingdom's armed forces
covenant
is the country's commitment to its armed
forces
it is a pledge that those who serve
or who have served
in a name in the armed forces and their
families should be treated with fairness
and respect
in their communities
economy
and society they serve it is i'm sorry
it is
backed by an annual allocation of
funding
of 10 million pounds
from central government
as well as by additional funding
for special projects arising
from the uk's covenant in addition
the armed forces act
2011
requires a secretary of state for
defense to prepare and present to
parliament an annual report on the
progress
in delivering a covenant of commitments
torres district council
our past signatories to the covenant and
have already established measures to
supply our armed forces personnel
and their families however we are
seeking to refresh this commitment and
expand the response
and support available within torridge in
line with current guidelines
the adoption of the government
is to recognize that torres district
council just
sorry plan for 2020
2023
so that's what i'm asking you to do
i mean i can go through the whole report
and i'm sure you'd be you know
but you should have already
i'm sure everyone is ready
so
i am asking for
this council
to support
infor the re-signing
of our new
improved covenant armed forces covenant
so your report will happen
i'm going to propose it from the chair
let's wait for a second now
just ask one question
this year i mean we haven't had
a lovely um before coleman the flag made
in ceremony down the park
and i see that's in in here as well is
that going to happen this year because i
figured out too and if it is going to
happen this year
we ought to get on and start organizing
that
it always was a very good event
[Music]
yeah part of the
the expectation of the government is
that we support events like that so and
that that's certainly something that we
would want to do and we will be signing
up to do as well as a number of events
of the year
council reaches second in general show
of hands in favor please
actually
thank you very much
[Music]
okay item 15 notices the motion we have
five notices of motion
two from councillor hudson one from
counter range
and then comes the forward one from
currently crazy we're going to
[Music]
[Music]
five counselors on in torridge
um i think it would be a good idea if
they came along
he just gave a report five to ten
minutes long
and if they do that in rotation
none of them would have to come more
than twice
in a year so
you know i just did and some of us
aren't parish councillors
and they we never see
or
[Music]
seldom see our county councillors
and i think it would be a good idea
that we invite them along
after all we only get eight and a half
percent of the council tax
um from what we and they they get 76
so perhaps we should
hold them accountable just a little bit
more i think
i'll go for a second
again
certainly not the secondary chair
um
i urge you councillors please don't
support this good heavens above
well that's really bad news isn't it
really
these species are long enough for you
to make good habits do you want another
another host coming along
it's not necessary
[Music]
a rare event i entirely agree with dr
brenton
so that that's really done you don't
know
um
our
our county councillors uh
are not answerable to us
uh and it is not their business to
answer here because if they come here
and give a report then other councillors
will want to poke them in the chest and
ask them to justify what they're doing
in this forum this is not the forum for
that counselor when you were a
conservative
county councillor i did you make this
request then
and can i answer it well
that's
every month
whether or not you know you read it or
not is up to you yeah that i did send my
reports every month
yeah
cancer custody you have to yeah thank
you i'd actually like to support
councillor inch on this because we
already have our county council for
business turn up
at the town council
and it's extremely helpful uh you can
all you can invite them one of them
doesn't come
that's beside the point um but they we
do get some really good feedback i
noticed from counter inches motion it
says you're inviting to speak for 10
minutes i hope there would be
an opportunity for questioning as well
because
the problem is that
local papers they may have shrunk but
they still do cover the local council
what do you read about the county
council
they seem to act on their own nobody
really knows what's happening up here
with the county councillors
you can go online you can watch their
debates but they're not the most
exciting um but we do actually need to
have our counselors come along
and talk to us
we are
three tears
already county counselors come along and
they talk to the bottom tier the town
council
they need to come along and talk to the
district as well so i'm going to second
council which is motion well that takes
care of the second and the debate so i'm
not alone anymore but i would just um
say councillor motion is uh for 10
minutes i said five minutes anticipating
that there would be people wishing to
speak so the motion will read five
minutes ago syringe i'm happy with that
all right
did you set it back
up
[Music]
kind of a show of hands and support
please
please
no
15
against 11
right
okay
council hudson i believe you're next for
your newest emotions
thank you
um i'm going to be as swift as possible
because i think
everybody's been sitting here for a long
time
my first notice of motion this evening
is to
look at the expansion of the criteria
we utilize for the allocation of our
counsellor 2 thousand pound grants
i want to make this grant
available to
everyone within our communities you'll
note that i say it's
not to include commercial interests
but just to expand the range of people
that we can actually support
we want to be able to or personally i
would like to be able to support
breakfast clubs in this time
where children are going to school
hungry
i would like to support
the projects
that we have for mental health
and where they need additional funding
some of you might say this isn't our
responsibility
but i believe at this moment in time
because of the pressures that all our
services
are facing
and all our community members are facing
we need to make sure that we give
everything we can
appropriately to support people getting
through this crisis
because it is a crisis
i am fortunate enough to have
grandchildren who go to school fed and
clothed and looked after
there are children out there that go to
school without any of these things
it's not just about that but it's about
the things we can support as counselors
and i ask you tonight to make sure
that we extend the flexibility of this
grant scheme
so we make the best use of our counselor
grants it's only two thousand pounds
each but it can make a difference
so i ask for your support tonight
thank you thank you
the most difficult cost to get
is core costs
and any organization does not run
without those course staff everything
has to be for something new a specific
project a piece of equipment but none of
those projects or pieces of equipment
can be used unless you've got that core
center and those poor staff are the ones
that
turn the wheels to make the
organization operate and they're the
hardest ones to get money for so i
totally support counsellors hudson's
motion and would like to propose it
i'll leave council mackenzie to sign up
first oh i'm just going to second the
chat okay
can i just ask one
question then um all the like the
breakfast clubs and that um they cannot
be in an individual person's name
they've got to be like dalton breakfast
club or you know they cannot be under
mrs smith so we still want
bank accounts from the organizations not
individuals yes that's quite right and
and this is where when an application is
made it will continue to be looked at in
the same way that it has but it just
extends the range for arguments say just
one example
i was told we can fund um
christmas um parcels food parcels from
the food bank
but we can't fund ordinary day-to-day
handing out of
vouchers or
food
costs it's about core costs so this is
why i want to if if they need it we
should be able to provide it
thank you thank you
so it's been
are there any other speakers
it's been proposed and seconded
all in favor of bishop
yes sorry
pausing
um
now again i'm not going to deliver a
long speech to you all tonight because i
did provide you all with background
papers
to this notice of motion
for the ocean
now tonight it's quite
symbolic for me that tonight we had a
guest speaker
who came to talk about the biosphere
and what we are doing there now we work
closely with the biosphere
and this motion
for the ocean
has been developed to help us as local
authorities play our part
in realizing a clean
productive ocean
and all the direct
economic health and well-being benefits
that it will bring
it also helps local authorities
communicate
the same evidence-based arts
around ocean recovery
directly to central government
ensuring a louder
united voice
if you looked at the documentation i
sent you
you will have seen that
plymouth city council have signed up to
it
farmer
south tyneside
and i can go on but i won't because
there are
lots and lots of local authorities
signing up and pledging their support
for this motion for the ocean
um
i am proposing that this motion for the
ocean is referred to cnr not for any
financial
commitment
but for agreement
to embed the principles into operational
practices
and future coastal education and
decision making we've heard tonight
about the fisheries
we've heard about the protected zones
around london
we need to work together to make sure
that policies for the future that we are
making
do not impact negatively
on our ocean
and i
propose this notice of motion to you and
fall for a second
um
and we've already committed to doing
that anyway much of this
in here seems to be things which we're
already doing anyway which is for me is
obviously good
the only issue i have with this is point
six with regard to writing to the
government
and lobbying them
as we've said before we're not a lobby
group
i i would wholeheartedly support the
rest of this but that that is uh is a
sticking point for me and i i wonder if
um council hudson would be willing to
amend it to take that part out
i also have one other question which was
i can see as you said it's been passed
by um
in other places can ask who
formulated this this motion please thank
you
all right um
um yes uh i belong or the
this local authority belongs to the
local authority
special interest group for coastal
resorts
um and this is
a national body
and there's uh member
members put together this notice of
motion for the ocean
and this is a well qualified marine
specialist who has proposed this to the
they call themselves the lac so it's a
bit quicker than saying the whole title
um
and this is a motion that has been
adopted and is being promoted amongst
the group of members now this is every
coastal area around the whole of the
united kingdom
north devon accepted it on the
22nd of february
there was an article in
yesterday's
past thursdays western morning news
extolling the virtues that they are
going to save the ocean
and i would implore you to join with
them
and we will have the entire north devon
coast protected
regarding your second point
the local authority special interest
group is
invited
to make proposals to government and
works with government groups
to actually promote
all sorts of areas of concern
they have a landfill site group
which counselor laws sits on
to discuss the issues around the
landfill to the whole of the nation
so they are invited
to
bring their ideas to government
and they are asking for our support to
bring these ideas to government to form
the protection of the ocean
so it's not quite the same as saying
you must
it's a question of we want to work
together with you
to do this because it is of great
consequence
so slightly different
thank you thanks for christie with you
yeah thank you um
yeah i support this whole
local government many years ago
because of raw sewage being pumped
straight into the torridge
it's
horrifying that 40 years later
it's still going in and i say that
because
um
several years ago i chaired a joint
working group between north devon and
torridge looking at the uh state of our
coastal waters and river waters we were
absolutely horrified when we found out
how many licenses there are to discharge
material entire rivers on top of that of
course we now know that southwest water
discharges material at high
flows
i was really interested when i read this
uh point two
where you talk about the um
our strategic planning especially the
planning and that's gonna be really
important because that working group i
cheered we actually are southwest water
what is the carrying capacity at
cornbread
they won't tell us
they're now because they've been
privatized you can't get freedom of
information
they will not tell us and yet we are
faced with thousands of extra houses
we really need to press this torridge
really needs to start asking some
serious questions
and i'm a bit surprised when i hear that
we shouldn't contact our mp because
we're not a lobbying group
we're contacting him on behalf of our
people
that's what we should be doing so i
wholeheartedly support this
okay well it's been proposed and
seconded
um i'm sure vance and supporters
thank you very much
okay the last
notion of motion because obviously
withdrawals is not here
is uh council craigie
and we're all getting married
and
i just would like to thank the business
town council and the ocean
for the amount of research and the work
that they've put into it
and they've done an excellent job and
they've come up with emotion which is
actually self-funding
so
something that the public are really
supporting we put out a request on
facebook we have those required people
telling us an empty home
um not all of them invented benefits
some of them in lawrence but um i'm sure
that you've all got empty homes in your
ward and i would ask you
even if the motion doesn't pass please
will you let the councils the council
know
if you have an empty home in your ward
that's been empty for two years because
they should be paying
extra accounting tax
and this is something that only 76
houses are actually doing
it's it's one of those taxes where you
report yourself
and
so i think there will be
quite a lot more homes that are not
paying it and if we can get them to pay
it and we can use that money to get
these homes back into working order and
use them for local people
so
thanks for everyone in the public who
has responded to our requests and if
anyone else would like to send
in
um
empty properties that they could send to
the council or send them to their town
thank you
mr james i'm sorry
as you know i do a lot with affordable
homes i'm a little bit concerned about
the actual motion
um because it does say about um
anti-homeless council tax premiums
should be ring fence to employ an empty
homes officer
if we collected all the rent all the
council attacks from 76 houses it would
amount to twelve and a half thousand
pound so we can't look at employing
somebody on that sort of money
and
the
to do with the empty host hose
management orders this council is
already working with
lendology which is a an organization
that lends money to empty homes
owners to win those houses up to
standard and so they can be let out or
they can be sold
and last year 2021 we actually have 21
properties in our area and given the
size of the houses we've got in this
area that's a fair proportion
and also um
you know we are we are continually
looking at empty homes and what we can
do with it so
whilst i'm not against the motion i
think the motion in itself is not going
to achieve what we want and i would
suggest that close with craig he comes
in and we discuss how we can actually
refine that how we can direct people
we've already talked about directing
doing a campaign about lendology to
drive
this forward to try and encourage more
home owners to do it um and as i say and
also with the premium that we already
credit which is very kind of ground it's
already allocated in the budget so we
don't have any money separate if we take
that at the budget we think i'll redo
the budget so at the moment i would
suggest we defer this well really i've
always focused you uh you know my
knowledge of um providing affordable
homes and i think we can actually refine
this to deliver what we can deliver
rather than raise aspirations overcome
so my advice would be to learn to move
otherwise i'll propose that as a council
until we can actually refine it
you've heard what the leader has said i
mean are you are you happy to go down
the route of having a meeting to refine
it so that it irons out some of the
issues that clearly are here
[Music]
is then withdrawal temporarily
deferred sorry
thank you
yeah
but unfortunately for those who are
watching us on youtube and any members
any individuals in the room that aren't
counselors we have to do with the part
two so can i have
[Music]
okay so this is item 18 temporary
accommodation